all right looks like we are set
to go um uh my name is barbara griffin
good morning everybody
this is the first meeting of the new
hampshire
house special committee on redistricting
this is a meeting that was noticed uh
for this morning at 10 o'clock i
apologize we are a couple of minutes
late
getting actually started here today
we have bills listed in the calendar to
be heard
um the reality is as we proceed into our
hearing
um there's sort of limited action that
we've got available to us on the bills
this morning but before we begin any of
that
um i'm gonna do the little preamble that
we need to do
for electronic meetings here in the
state
and there is a sign up sheet
for this committee meeting and the bill
is being heard
the sign up sheets stop at 8 a.m this
morning as far
as the committee proceeds but you will
be able to continue to sign up until
11 59 tonight there will be the
opportunity for a public hearing
at the end of the presentation of the
bills
and there's a process for being
recognized on the zoom platform so
members are aware it is my understanding
that no one has signed up
in regards to this meeting this morning
as chair of the special committee on
redistricting i find that due to the
state of emergency declared by the
governor as a result of the covet 19
pandemic and in accordance with house
rule 67 and the
governor's emergency order number 12
pursuant to executive order 2020.04
this public body is authorized to meet
electronically this is a public hearing
on the bills that are referred to
committee and they have been scheduled
in the house calendar for today
an executive session may be held on any
bill referred to the committee please
note that there is no physical location
for members of the public to observe
and listen contemporaneously and all
members are attending electronically
however in accordance with the emergency
order i am confirming that
all members of the committee and select
legislative staff have the ability to
communicate
contemporaneously during this meeting
through the zoom electronic meeting
platform
and the public has asked access to
contemporaneously listen
and if necessary participate in this
meeting by the zoom platform or by
telephone
all necessary access information has
been made available in the house
calendar
and through the electronic calendar on
the general court website
the notice for this meeting does comply
with house rules and rsa 91
a anyone who has a problem accessing
this meeting please call 271
3600 or email hcs at
ledge leg dot state
and in the event we learn that the
public is unable to access this meeting
the meeting will be
adjourned and rescheduled please note
that
any votes taken during this meeting will
be done by roll call vote
and we're going to start that process by
taking a roll call
attendance and when each person states
their present i'm going to ask that they
state whether there is anyone in the
room with you during this meeting
which is required under the right to
know law
representative mcdonald has kindly
agreed
to do the roll call this morning for me
so i'm going to ask
representative mcdonald to do that at
this time
good morning and thank you madam
chairman um
representative griffin i am present and
alone uh representative steve smith
i am in room 113 at the state house
there is one staff member here
thank you representative mcguire
present at my home in epsom my husband
is not here now but he may be late
thank you representative charcot
representative turcotte is here at home
my wife is in her office at the other
end of the house
thank you uh representative mcdonald is
present
representative lynn uh yes i'm present
in my home in windham my wife
no one else is in the room but my wife
is elsewhere in the house
thank you and and by the way
representative mcdonald is home alone
representative barry uh yes i am here
in manchester in my office uh my fiance
is upstairs doing her
work from home job thank you
i will just note his fiancee soon to be
wife
representative o'hara
i am here i'm in my office alone thank
you
representative cody i'm here and
i'm at home and i'm alone thank you
representative smith i'm i'm in
durham alone thank you
representative bergeron uh in accordance
with the governor's emergency order i'm
participating remotely from my home in
nashua
there was there is no one in the room
with me at the present time
thank you representative lane
uh yes i'm here in concord in my home
office i'm alone in the office there are
two other people in the house thank you
and i hope i pronounced his name right
representative piedra
that's correct present and alone in the
room thank you
representative weber i'm present i'm in
the walpole town
hall where i'm also serving as a ballot
clerk so there are many many people
but i fled upstairs in hopes of being
alone in the room until we're finished
with the meeting here
thank you thank you
and representative wilhelm present and
alone in the room
uh the rest of my family's upstairs
thank you
thank you all members are present
thank you very much representative
mcdonald for doing that and thank you
everybody for attending
thank you to representative weber for
serving at the town elections which are
going on in many communities today
um i will be at the polls in goffstown
shortly after this meeting for the rest
of the day so
i know most of a lot of your communities
do have things that i will say
if i could please take the liberty of
saying good morning representative smith
it's nice to see you on zoom
in in the flesh and not in the picture
so i
i i got to get that picture background
figured out but
good morning
well it's always a pleasure to see you
uh madam chair
thanks all right um
let's see so the purpose of the meeting
that has been scheduled has been to
officially receive the bills for
redistricting before this special
committee
before deadlines there's been some
change to the deadlines but this hearing
was scheduled before that was known
the reality is is that i think most of
you know we have no redistricting data
to use to begin our work
uh that is not expected to be available
until september
i think the the official federal word is
sort of on or before september 30th
i think the initial release dates were
expected to be
april so it has significantly impacted
the
time frame that we have to do the work
and as a result while the rules require
us to take this bill into committee
there really is nothing
that we can do on it before our
deadlines for action to be voted on by
the floor
it is my hope that we can
receive the bills retain them
and see if there's anybody attending who
wants to make a comment
um and then have a brief discussion
about scheduling a meeting where we
discuss
what's going to happen in regards to
consideration of these bills in the
future
from a scheduling standpoint for the
committee at which time we can get into
discussion of how we're going to proceed
because
i i want to proceed as a committee with
everybody involved
so with that we are scheduled to hear
hb 50 51 52 53
54 and 55 at 10 a.m
they all relate to apportioning
districts
i am the prime sponsor on these bills
uh i want to thank representative smith
i am going to defer
to representative smith for the
introduction
of these bills welcome representative
smith
thank you madam chair and members of the
committee for hearing me today i'm
representative steven smith
sullivan county district 11 towns of
akworth goshen langdon webster and
washington i'm here to introduce the
bills that our chair has graciously
prepared for us
house bill 50 apportioning state
representative districts
house bill 51 apportioning state senate
districts
house bill 52 apportioning congressional
house bill 53 apportioning executive
council districts
house bill 54 apportioning county
commissioner districts
and house bill 55 apportioning delegates
to state party conventions
my understanding is that the text of the
bills as written and presented to the
committee
represent the current state of
redistricting since we don't have
anything to work with yet
and i urge the committee to retain all
six bills so that we have vehicles to do
our work throughout the year
thank you madam chair thank you
representative smith
does anybody have any questions for
is there anybody in attendance who would
like to make a comment
um
um i i do see a couple of hands ms zinke
and miss tentarelli i i do
see you um but i'm gonna sort of
ask my tech support it does not appear
that
i am listed as a co-host
and i cannot recognize i'm
you thank you very much now i can great
um ms inc good morning welcome
good morning members of the committee
and um thank you for the opportunity to
speak on the redistricting bill
um for the record my name is olivia zink
i'm the executive director of a
nonpartisan
pro-voter non-profit open democracy
action based in concord and i live in
franklin
i do want to tell you that your link for
sign up
for the hearing was not working so the
reason you have no one signed up
is because there was no ability on the
um
website for community for community
members to sign up
today 30 towns around new hampshire will
be voting on a resolution for fair
redistricting at their ballot
at town meeting four cities have passed
this uh resolution as well as the town
of durham town council
by large margins i think this is an
issue that's
important to everyone
and well we don't need to dwell on what
happened 10 years ago i think it's
important that this committee understand
the history and work as well as they can
for a fair nonpartisan redistricting
process
free from using partisan data for the
years
for the for the next 10 years thank you
for the opportunity to
to speak madam chair and members of the
committee
does anybody have any questions for ms
zinc for mayor's inc
um i have a question representative lane
um could you provide a copy of that
um uh resolution or whatever
you referenced to committee just email
it or have you already done so and i
just missed it
um no i'm happy to email um the
the communities and i'm happy to email
you the the one that the city of
franklin
passed um as well but i think um
as cities i'll just speak from the the
city perspective
our city lions are in our charter and
with the data that are coming out
september 30th there will be no ability
for our city
and the city of franklin to amend our
charter which is an october election
um before you do your work so we will
probably be
be doing that in a different time frame
so i think with the delay in the
in the data this year we'll also have to
think about how how do the
municipal lines that have to be drawn
play into your work as well
thank you
thank you any other questions from his
zinc
okay thank you for being here this
morning also with their hand raised to
speak to the committee is liz tentarelli
good morning
ms tentarelli if you unmute i think
you're with us
thank you for this opportunity i too uh
realized that there was no way for us to
sign up ahead of time to speak
and i just sent you email representative
griffin to that effect
but i do want to thank all of you for
being willing to serve on this very
important committee
i know it's going to be a tremendous job
that you have to do
i'm sorry i forgot to introduce myself
liz tentarelli i'm president of the
league of women voters a non-partisan
organization
and i want to assure you that the league
stands
ready to do its part in helping you in
any way we can
whether that is publicizing open
meetings that you're going to hold to
get
input or just letting
voters know about the work that you're
doing i have great confidence that this
committee will be open and transparent
in its work they will solicit
input from municipal and county
officials to find communities of
interest
and other areas of concern so i
i wish you all the best and i look
forward to your meeting when you
actually start doing the work
thank you very much thank you very much
for joining us this morning is there
anybody who has a question for ms
tentarelli
i'm not seeing any so uh thank you very
much for speaking at this time i'd like
to ask whether there's
anybody else in attendance i see 16
people
um have logged on to this meeting and if
anybody else would like to say anything
if you could raise your hand we would
certainly recognize you
all right representative maguire did you
have something
yes thank you madam chair this is
something that
happened in the previous
redistricting which i know about only
peripherally
and it's a policy decision that we need
to make before we actually start
crunching numbers
i i live in one of three towns on the
edge of merrimack county
the populations add up to four
uh well within the the uh
plus or minus five percent
the every each of the three towns has
enough population from at least one
representative
but last last last redistricting
we determined that because of the plus
or minus five percent
on floatarials instead of having one
district
in each of the three towns with one
representative
and one in the float we ended up with
two of the towns
being combined in a base district and
the third one
separate and then one in the float and
people who were working on the previous
redistricting
told me that if 12 people
had moved from the larger town to the
smaller town
we could have gotten the one one one
plus a float which
many of the people in the towns would
prefer
and i determined that that was because
of the way
the plus or minus five percent from
one man one vote was being applied to
floaterials
and i think that in this case
the result was not what most of the
people would have wanted
it violates our constitutional provision
that every town that's big enough has
its own representative
and therefore i think we as a committee
should be looking at how we do those
calculations so it doesn't happen again
to somebody else
thank you i know that i myself come from
a town that's part of a floatario
i i think that it will i think that the
census data will be quite interesting
because i think there has been a big
change in population in the state over
the last 10 years
and we are very fortunate to have with
us someone who actually was
part of the prior process as far as i
know
and that would be representative weber
and representative
weber i see that you have your hand up
um
please join us with audio thank you
and chair and just to add to the
thoughts of the
prior speaker i will note that i
am in a four-member four-town district
which after our constitutional amendment
that said that each town that had more
than
the magic number which was 3291 the last
time around
would get their own representative my
district actually got larger
as a result of that i i now represent
four towns
uh the one of which takes me nearly an
hour to get to the other end of
um and we too are
in a clump where three of us are
entitled to our own reps but
there is a possibility that the town of
westmoreland could
elect four representatives and the other
three towns have none
so i just put that into the mix as yet
another
issue where we are going to find that we
are
unable to satisfy both the new hampshire
constitution which requires us
each town that has the requisite number
to have its own representation
and the federal requirement that each
person's vote weighs equally
and that's because we choose not to do
census districts
when every other state most every other
state does
many other states i don't know the exact
numbers
but it's it's a fact of life that we're
going to have to grapple with
and i just throw that out there as
another another fish to be dealt with
thank you well and the uh and
representative weber thank you for your
experience and your ability to just
recall the 3491 number
because of course we can expect that
number to change because the population
has of course changed
so individually we're all going to be
looking at a district that
it's going to be probably unlikely that
it stays
exactly the same just by virtue of the
population growth and shift that's
occurred over the last 10 years
so that of course is going to be a
discussion on the committee not only
between us
but with our constituents in regards to
that there has been
much talk about a public hearing process
i will tell you that i'm aware that
there there were complaints about the
public hearing process that occurred
last time i don't
really know there was a complaint that
they were sort of hearings with no data
this is going to create a dilemma for
the committee because if we don't have
any data until september
and we need to do something for next
year um
really how are we going to go about our
work we're going to
we're going to be able to follow that's
meaningful for everybody
and i think quite frankly that's a
meeting in and of itself
um just to discuss um the options that
are out there and how we proceed
so while we have bills in front of us
that i'll be looking for
to retain on so we can continue our work
on them
um i would like to have some discussion
about
when given the calendar for the house
that we have right now and what we
expect coming
um i frankly i am not looking at a next
meeting
of this committee for it till after
mid-april
with the things that are going on and i
just want to know
sort of from a committee standpoint does
anybody have
any specific considerations that should
be taken
into account in regards to scheduling
representative weber i don't but i
do note that scheduling this
term is much more difficult because we
do not have dedicated days on which our
committees meet
and my committee meets mondays and
fridays
uh occasionally which
were the days that used to be protected
for special committees
so scheduling is going to be a complete
nightmare but
like everybody else on the screen here i
have no idea what my schedule
is going to be until thursday afternoon
of the week before
when the calendar comes out so that's
going to be a challenge for you madam
chair
all right look forward working we'll
figure out and try to do the best we can
i
anticipate at least for our committee
work initially um
it's probably going to continue as the
zoom platform it gives us flexibility to
participate that representative weber
would appear to be the best example of
how to be flexible and do it
today representative bergeron i noticed
you had your hand up
um i'm sorry i did not recognize you
were you all set or did you want to say
something
well i think i just want to share a
little information to uh
build upon what miss zinc said about
some of the problems with cities
i did the redistricting in nashua in
2001 and 2011
and in both instances the war data
provided by the u.s census bureau
their ward boundaries did not follow our
actual ward
and as a result we use this the us
census data to create
our ward lines only to find out we had
to go back to the voters of nashua to
redraw those lines
after gis showed us that some of the
census tracts that
the census bureaus belonged in one ward
were actually
uh covering two wards manchester had the
same problem i don't know
if it occurred in both 2011 and 2001
but again the census boundaries didn't
match up with the actual ward boundaries
in most instances the cities can deal
with that internally
in their own redistricting for their
ward lines but if there are floaters
that cross over into cities
that's going to be a concern i think as
well for our committee
thank you for that information
representative lynn
yes uh thank you madam chair i guess the
only question i had
in light of the fact that uh the census
data will not be available
until september i'm i guess i i mean
don't get me wrong you tell me when when
to be there and i'll be there but i'm
i'm not quite sure i understand what
um what is what will be the purpose of
the meetings you were talking about
having for example in april and may i if
we
if we don't have the data what what are
we what are we going to do with those
meetings
representative lynn thank you for the
question i think there needs to be a
discussion with the committee about the
process
welcome to the new hampshire house this
year redistricting is not a new issue
for
anybody who has been in this house for
the last few sessions
it has been a subject of
legislation now for a few sessions
with different results from different
sessions
and there has been much input as to into
the process that should be followed and
it is my belief that if we wait until we
have the data
to discuss how we are proceeding
we will be spending more time with each
other
than anybody else in our lives come
october 1st
so it is my hope that we can
as a committee come together with some
sort of a process
as to how to proceed and it might be
that why public
while public hearings without data were
a complaint apparently of the last
session
given our ability to do it on the zoom
platform
we might want to have some input into
the issue of
communities and their representation
as to the floatarial issues so we have
some background on
individual communities i can tell you on
the election law committee
we have heard for a few sessions from
members of communities who got
sucked into a floaterial in the last
redistricting and as a result
effectively felt they lost their
representatives so
um i think those kind of things can be
heard without necessarily having
the actual data in front of us
representative smith
if you thank you very much madam chair
um i believe you're recognizing me i
just want to point out that with two
smiths on
the committee you're going to have to
train yourself
to decide or to to include a first name
or some other way of
of differing which smith you're calling
never
occurred to me until you said that thank
you
i fortunately realized you hadn't asked
me to introduce the bills so i knew that
was representative steven smith
i want to uh second enthusiastically
what the chair just
said we have process and we have
substance
at the moment the substance is
uh just not available to us
at the moment that it is we're going to
want to be
ready to go on there are all kinds of
process decisions that this committee
could and i believe should make
um one of them that's been mentioned
several times
is the importance of having public
meaningful public input um
and where in fact we do have um
uh public hearings where
there is data for the public to evaluate
that we can't do
until we have the data but in terms of
process
there's a lot that we can do we can try
to
develop guidelines about
floaterial districts we can
gather guidelines about
public input we can gather uh
guidelines about the factors that we
want to
include when we
set up lines we can look at the
constitutional
requirements and see both national
and state and see what we want to do
to make sure that we have districts
that conform as closely as possible
to city and town
lines we know we can't cross counties
that i think is a rule that we're all
willing to observe for the house
although obviously not for the senate or
executive or any of the others but if we
could get
a lot of those process questions
um uh through this committee and have a
sense of where we want to go
before we are influenced even
by the specific numbers i think we would
be sending a message
to the public and to ourselves
that we really want this to be as fair
and open a process as is possible
and so i commend the chair for
recognizing that
process is important and we can have
that
under our belt so to speak before we get
the first
number thank you
thank you representative marjorie smith
anybody else on the committee
all right um we have before us
six bills that have been introduced hb
50 through
55 representative steven smith would you
have a motion
yes and well first inquiry of the chair
certainly
should the motion be for all six bills
or do you prefer to take them up one at
a time
pam you're on i'm going to defer to you
really um yes i've i've never
seen a um a group um
vote on on multiple bills at the same
time
fair enough hi i know it sounds
like you're going to do the exact same
thing six times in a row but
so i apologize uh representative
mcdonald
if you want to take that attendance
sheet out you're going to need
to go through it apparently six
more times for me thank you very much
for
i will tell the committee that we have
begun the process with the clerk's
office
and administrative services as to what
kind of support is going to be available
to this committee
um i don't know if your
committees that you serve on have had
any emails from constituents i can tell
you the election law committee has had a
few and
as a result um the work of the clerk
on that committee has expanded
exponentially from what it has been in
prior years
dealt only with paper input um so i will
be
working with um those offices at the
house to find out what kind of support
we can get but in anticipation that
um we will have a significant amount of
electronic input
representative mcdonald are you set with
the sheet to take
a roll if representative smith makes a
motion
i am yes madam chairman thank you
representative smith for a motion please
thank you madam chair i move that house
bill 50 be retained
is there a second to that motion
representative mcguire seconds it
um i'm going to ask the clerk to call
the roll
and i would just remind
members that when you vote the rule as i
understand it
is i need to um actually see you
um and so um when your name is called if
you can just click on the video that
would be great so representative donald
if you want to proceed
representative weber question could the
clerk very kindly or the chair
announce the title of the bill that we
are voting on
sure the bill on the floor is hd 50 that
is apportioning
state representative districts
and if the clerk could call the role
uh representative smith yes
i'm sorry it's representative stephen
smith representative mcguire
yes representative trecott
representative turcotte could you when
you thinking
yeah i was using my space bar didn't
work uh yes
uh representative mcdonald votes yes uh
representative lynn
yes representative barry
yes representative o'hara
yes representative cody
yes representative marjorie smith
yes representative bergeron
yes representative lane
yes representative piedra
yes representative weber
yes representative wilhelm
yes and representative griffin
yes uh the vote carries to
15 to zero hb 50
will be reported as retained by the
committee
representative smith do you stephen
smith do you have a motion
you madam chair thank you i move that
house bill 51
apportioning state senate districts be
retained
is there a second representative
turcotte
representative lane did you have a
question
yes manager uh point of order do we need
to be an executive session to vote
or i'm still learning the process so i
just
the court calendar has allowed us to
take the notice through the calendar
allows us to
executing committees we try not to do it
the same day as
a public hearing but we are permitted
under the notice rules
to do it okay i just didn't know if you
had to announce it
at that time oh as i didn't actually say
executive session excuse me for um
not specifically saying we're in
executive session for the purposes of
considering bill's um
we are in executive session thank you
for making that clear on the record
i just didn't want to have somebody
raise it after we're all done and have
to go through this again
well okay this is a good way to control
the issues though don't you think
[Laughter]
all right there's been a motion on the
floor to to retain
hb 51 it sent by representative
turcotte is there any comment on the
motion on the floor
seeing none i'll ask the representative
mcdonald to call the role
thank you madam chairman representative
stephen smith yes
representative mcguire yes
representative turcotte yes
representative mcdonald votes yes
representative lynn
yes representative barry
yes representative o'hara
yes representative cody
yes representative smith
yes i'll learn uh representative
bergeron
yes representative lane
yes representative piedra
yes representative weber
yes representative wilhelm
yes and representative griffin
yes 15-0 madam chairman
thank you
representative stephen smith do you have
a motion in this executive session
on the special committee on
redistricting you madam chair thank you
i move that house bill 52 apportioning
congressional districts be retained
is there a second
no second madam chairman representative
mcdonald's second is there any
discussion on the motion
um see none i'll call for the vote
representative mcdonald representative
steven smith
yes did somebody have a question no i i
apologize
to the committee i was chuckling because
representative mcguire's husband the
honorable mcguire
appeared on screen i'm not sure that
constitutes
his photo bombing but it was still
something that i picked up
representative stephen smith yes
representative mcguire yes
representative charcot yes
representative mcdonald votes yes
representative lynn
yes representative barry
yes representative o'hara
thank you representative cody
yes thank you representative marjorie
smith
yes representative bergeron
yes representative lane
yes representative piedra
yes representative weber
yes representative wilhelm
yes 15-0 madam chairman
thank you representative mcdonald
um representative smith do you have a
motion
i do madam chair i move that house bill
apportioning executive council districts
be retained
is there a second representative mcguire
seconds
is there any discussion on the motion
seeing none i'll ask representative
mcdonald to call the rule
representative stephen smith yes
representative mcguire yes
representative turcotte yes
representative mcdonald votes yes
representative lynn
yes representative barry
yes representative o'hara
yes representative cody
yes representative marjorie smith
yes representative bergeron
yes representative lane
yes representative piedra
excuse me yes representative weber
yes yes
uh representative wilhelm yes
and representative griffin yes
15-0 madam chairman thank you
representative smith do you have a
motion thank you madam chair thank you
i move that house bill 54 apportioning
county commissioner districts be
retained
is there a second representative
turcotte seconds
is there any discussion on the motion
before the committee which is to retain
h.b 54 apportioning county commissioner
districts
i'm seeing none if representative
mcdonald's could call the role please
representative stephen smith yes
representative mcguire yes
representative chaircott yes
representative mcdonald votes yes
representative lynn
yes representative barry
yes representative o'hara
yes representative cody
yes representative marjorie smith
yes representative bergeron
yes representative lane
yes representative piedra
yes representative weber
yes representative wilhelm
yes and representative griffin
yes 15-0 madam chairman
thank you representative smith do you
have a motion
i do thank you madam chair i move that
house bill 55
apportioning delegates to state party
conventions be retained
is there a second representative mcguire
sec is there any discussion on the
motion
motion is to retain hb 55
seeing none i'll ask representative
mcdonald to please call the rule
representative stephen smith yes
representative mcguire yes
representative chaircott yes
representative mcdonald votes yes
representative lynn
yes representative barry
yes representative o'hara
yes representative cody
yes representative marjorie smith
yes representative bergeron
yes representative lane
yes representative piedra
yes representative weber
yes and representative wilhelm
yes and representative griffin yes
15-0 madam chairman thank you very much
thank you very much hb 50 51
52 53 54 and 55 will be reported
to the clerk's office as being retained
i have not checked with the clerk's
office on this particular item that i'm
going to say but i want to congratulate
you all
as being part of the committee that has
just taken six
unanimous votes in a row it is the
first for me i suspect it's the first
for many of you this session so there
you go
the sign of things to come on this who
knows who knows does
anybody have anything else that they'd
like to bring before the committee this
morning
uh yes ma'am chair i'd just like to say
nothing i've done today should have
stopped me from objecting should you
choose once again to
to take up bills on the same day i
haven't
abandoned my objection to that thank you
representative cody for reminding
me i appreciate consistency
in legislators and legislation whenever
i can find it and i can count on you for
that so thank you very much
all right um i want to thank you all for
joining us
i there will be a notice as i said for a
meeting to start the process discussion
as
representative marjorie smith discussed
um
i just want to say uh representative
weber have a good day at the polls
and for those of you in your communities
many of you have a voting day go vote so
thank you very much everybody
representative weber
you need to unmute thank you i'm
operating in my lap so
the space bar is working but only when i
press really firmly
i just wanted to make a plea
that before you schedule the next
hearing you also discuss with your
fellow chairs as to when they're going
to be meeting
because as we know they are going to be
meeting
every day of the week and as as somebody
who has chaired a second committee
in the past it's very helpful when
people are not stuck trying to go to two
meetings at the same time it will help
our deliberative process and would be
very much appreciated
when you get around to the scheduling
thank you thank you we will
do our best there is a zoom license
um quantity number we have to pass the
bar to get in the door and then we'll
check to see what you all have scheduled
we'll do
our best thank you everybody for
attending thank you to the attendees for
being here with us this morning and all
of you have a great day i hear it's nice
and sunny out bye bye now bye